hey soldier we're here on our day two at
Australia here at the Sydney I'm Justin
do you want to explain to them what you
think
what was your description okay so I
describe Sydney as kind of like Milan or
Rome because it has all these cool
little coffee cafes and flower shops
outside and people kind of gather around
outdoors but then it feels like kind of
white San Francisco yeah because look
there's the Apple Store look at you
I try to use that with me here but they
don't take it because it's not
Australian credit card linked to it you
get what you get I got this one this is
so hits or I'm done using AK just snap
it together wait a month okay now I kind
of want to get this on now this is nice
thought Pizza Hut yesterday things are
very much like they are back homes
spotted hugs actually not at all made in
Australia so they're probably made in
China we have tried to get on escalators
oh my goodness
the camo okay the entire trip it's
unfortunately going to consist of me
just eating a lot of we're honey
Athenian Athenian so far we've got what
is that
Vicki popping you did order lamb brains
in you all right let's go
I don't like it at all it's not a
machine that just not good you made this
decision
so we're this bathroom right now and
it's kind of ridiculous because when we
walked in this box
okay wash your hands washing hands oh
there was like wait what we were
supposed to be going on our way through
our line this bridge and it is now down
the rain is not so not so good
I wonder if Oh going up on a Tuesday
this is great look out for your mates